In order to create motion, we first
need to be able to keep track of time.
LibGDX provides a fantastic
TimeUtils package to make this easy.
There are two main methods of interest,
TimeUtils.milis and TimeUtils.nanoTime.
Let's say this is a timeline and
this is right now.
What TimeUtils.millis()
gives you is the number of
milliseconds between right now and
January 1st 1970.
This is great if you want to know what
time it is, like the time on a wall
clock, but it's not always the best
choice for measuring time intervals.
When games are rendered
at 60 frames per second,
individual milliseconds start to matter.
So it's often best to use the more
precise TimeUtil of nanoTime.
nanoTime gives the time in nanoseconds.
That's billionths of a second.
But it doesn't have a definite reference
time, so if this is right now,
TimeUtils.nanoTime might give you
the number of nanoseconds since like
sometime in 2005, or it actually might
be a negative number of nanoseconds
from now until sometime in the future.
However, what nanoTime does allow us
to do is to measure time intervals.
So our general procedure is to save
the time that our game was created, and
then all future times can be measured
with respect to that creation time.
Let's check it out.